it definitely takes some time to make
but it's so worth it beef wellington is
the dish you make when you're looking to
impress family and friends it's that
perfect balance of a tender interior
with a flaky crust we tested this recipe
so many different ways to try and make
it as fool-proof as possible so that if
this is your first time making it you
will knock it out of the park
we're going to start with our duck cell
it's just a fancy name for a mixture of
finely chopped mushrooms and shallots
that have been cooked down
for a duck style you can use a variety
of mushrooms baby bellas which are also
known as creminis they're super savory
and meaty and shiitakes which are rich
and buttery
and trumpet mushrooms because they're
nutty and earthy
we really like this combo for the
ultimate umami flavor now this may be
controversial but we're using a food
processor to finally dice our mushrooms
you could also do this by hand it'll
definitely give you more control over
how fine your dice is but it will just
take you twice as long so we like to
pulse ours in short bursts to make sure
we don't turn our mushrooms into a paste
the next thing we want to do is remove
all the moisture from our mushrooms
often this is done on a stovetop but we
found this means spending a lot of time
standing around tending to the mushrooms
so instead we found it's easier to place
them on a large baking sheet and cook
them in the oven at 300 degrees
fahrenheit stirring every 15 minutes
until all of their moisture is
completely gone this usually takes about
45 minutes if we don't get the moisture
out now we'll end up with a soggy pastry
and nobody wants that while the
mushrooms are cooking we can get started
with our tenderloin this cut of beef
when cooked just right melts in your
mouth when we purchased our tenderloin
we asked for a center cut so that we get
a nice even shape if you do order a
whole tenderloin you just want to make
sure to cut off the ends so that you
have that beautiful center cut shape
first thing we're going to do is we're
going to trust this meat so that we can
make sure to keep the shape even when we
sear it to truss it we're going to need
some butcher's twine and some scissors
we'll measure the twine out six times
the length of the tenderloin
then wrap the twine around one end of
the loin and tie a knot to secure the
string
then make a loop around your hand with
the string
and place it around the loin about one
inch down from the first knot
then just continue looping and placing
the twine until you reach the end then
tie the string together in a knot to
lock it in place and we'll season this
guy with a generous amount of salt and
pepper and we mean be generous seasoning
the meat is really going to help us
build delicious levels of flavor so
don't be afraid of how much salt we're
using in a cast iron pan we're going to
heat up our vegetable oil over
medium-high heat so we're using a cast
iron because it conducts heat well and
it's a heavy bottom pan so it'll help
prevent the fat from burning and we're
going to use vegetable oil for searing
because of its high smoke point if we
used just butter it would burn from the
high heat don't worry the butter is
coming later once the oil is shimmering
we're going to sear the loin on all
sides really quickly it takes about a
minute on each side we really want to be
careful not to overcook the meat so
don't worry about it getting perfectly
golden brown right now we're really just
trying to lock in the moisture cool the
sides are looking good so we're going to
remove it from the heat and cut off the
twine then we're gonna brush it right
away with some mustard you can really
use any kind of mustard for this but we
really loved using like a spicy
horseradish mustard we're doing this
just to add a touch of acidity so make
sure you do this while the meat is still
hot so it absorbs the mustard and all of
its flavor
once it's completely covered we'll let
this chill for about an hour in the
fridge don't skip this step cooling it
down really helps it hold its shape now
it's time to get back to our duck cell
so in the same cast iron pan we used to
sear our meat we'll bring the heat back
up to medium-low and add some butter we
could watch melting butter all day let's
just do a vid on melting butter then
we'll add in our shallots and our garlic
basically everything that's good we're
gonna let all this cook until the
shallots have caramelized now really
take your time with this we really want
them to be soft and golden brown then
we're gonna deglaze with a little bit of
cognac deglazing is when you hit the pan
with a liquid so that it really lifts
all of those delicious brown bits from
the bottom of the pan
after the alcohol has cooked off we'll
stir in our mushrooms moisture is our
enemy in this dish so make sure the
liquid has really reduced it's smelling
so good in here right now like that lock
in the door and want to know what's
cooking good so once all that's combined
we'll remove it from the heat and place
it in a bowl cover it with plastic just
really make sure you press the plastic
down against the mushrooms
and then we're going to let it chill in
the fridge for about 45 minutes dude
we're halfway there
this next part not only makes the beef
wellington taste crazy delicious but it
works as a moisture barrier between the
beef and the puff pastry and it helps to
prevent any gaps in your final product
then we're going to evenly spread out
the mushrooms on top making sure to
leave a little border around the edges
and we're going to press them down to
make a compact flat layer so we'll
gently place the tenderloin at the
bottom third of the rectangle and we're
going to use the plastic wrap to really
help roll the prosciutto and the
mushrooms around the tenderloin it's
super helpful to hold the ends of the
plastic wrap and just roll the log to
get a tight seal
now we're going to place this back in
the fridge for about an hour i know
we're back in the fridge we're going to
do this a few times but really it's
going to ultimately help our
presentation in the end for that
perfectly round beef wellington shape
just when the meat is all the way
chilled we're gonna take a sheet of puff
pastry and roll it out until it's large
enough to cover our entire log make sure
your puff pastry is completely thawed
before you're rolling it if it's too
warm and tacky it will stick and rip as
you roll it out and if it's too cold
it'll crack so you really just gotta
find that nice middle ground
and then we're gonna brush the top third
of the puff pastry with a beaten egg
now we're gonna place the tenderloin on
the bottom third roll it up into a tight
log
it's kind of like wrapping a present be
gentle and take your time and then fold
the sides of the pastry and press under
the log
then we're gonna set it on a large sheet
of plastic wrap and we'll roll it up
real tight again using that rolling
method to really help us get that round
shape
you guessed it this guy's going back in
the fridge while we preheat our oven to
425 degrees we're so close to just hang
in there now it's time for the fun part
decorating first thing we're going to do
is we're going to brush our entire
wellington with some egg wash and this
next part is totally customizable and
really whatever you feel most
comfortable with
some people use a special tool to get
that perfect lattice design and others
just use a knife to score the pastry
we're using strips of puff pastry to
make our own lattice and it gets a
little fussy but just take your time
make a beautiful design
don't stress it
and for funsies we've cut out some fall
shapes like these leaves and you can
just place them wherever just have fun
with it
we finished our work of art look at her
she's beautiful and now it's time to
bake now we're going to throw it in the
oven for about 30 to 40 minutes
it's really tough to tell when the beef
is perfectly cooked if you're looking
for that medium rare finish you know
that it's done when the internal
temperature is 125 degrees fahrenheit
like any steak we want to make sure to
let it rest before we slice it
guys we did it we got here and now it's
finally time to eat serve this guy with
some of your favorite sides cut yourself
a slice and enjoy all of your hard work
and all the compliments from your
friends and family if you like this
recipe you can find it and many more on
tasty.com
oh what's the beef you can hardly
believe it
oh no no no i don't think
[Music]
you